this was a really big story at the time
that you made
kate cry now you're saying you didn't
make cake cry
kate made you cry new details have come
out following meghan markle and prince
harry's explosive interview with oprah
winfrey
it wasn't a confrontation and i actually
think it's
i don't think it's fair to her to get
into the details of that because she
apologized okay and i've forgiven her
right e.t has learned despite this much
talked about revelation
megan is quote grateful for her
sister-in-law kate middleton
i think for kate who's always been very
discreet you don't hear about her having
rows or falling out with people i think
this will be
very upsetting the source a close friend
of the couple
tells et quote the point of raising who
made who cry was not to disparage the
duchess of cambridge
i think that this argument that
obviously happened behind closed doors
has been dragged back up
and the duchess has been involved has
really upset william he's
very very protective of kate and it will
be very upsetting for him that she's
been dragged into this
the source adds quote it was simply to
highlight how differently they were
treated
and in fact quote meg is incredibly
grateful to the duchess who sent her
flowers
according to the source this will allow
them to move forward
well it was no secret of course that
william and harry
had fallen out even before the interview
it was widely reported that harry and
william's relationship
had taken a turn for the worse harry
himself said that they were on different
paths
but i think what has really upset
william is is kate being dragged into
the interview and now it's unclear where
the brothers will go from here
i was told by sources that he is beyond
livid over this interview and the damage
that hit has done
and i do know the behind the scenes you
know kate really has
tried to be a peacemaker and and
certainly tried to get the brothers back
on an even keel so
i think yeah she she will certainly be
upset to have been pulled into this
it's been less than a week after harry
and megan's special with oprah aired
and our source says it was quote
cathartic for the duke and duchess of
sussex
and they both felt positive about the
interview well we saw the queen reach
out
with yet another olive branch to the
sussexes and i think it is very much the
case
that she wants to smooth things over
another source tells et quote
the interview was raw true picture of
the state of the relationship between
the couple and the royal family
the source adds quote they still have a
lot of warmth for their family
especially
the queen but there is work to be done
the queen is
in her twilight years now she wants to
leave the monarchy in a good
strong place the monarchy is all about
unity
and this fragmentation this rupture
these riffs
at the center of it i'm not doing the
monarchy any good